y precisamente para hablar de la recta
final de la temporada regular saludamos
a nuestra invitada a la periodista
especializada marimontes miembro de la
asociación estadounidense de escritores
de béisbol Mari Un gusto tenerte acá con
nosotros igual para mí encantada de
hablar toda la audiencia Bueno sobre
esta pelea final esto últimos días de la
temporada 2022 y obviamente uno de los
temas que tiene mayor interés es Quién
será el jugador más valioso entre Aaron
George y show Halo tanny Yo creo que con
sus dos cuadrangulares de hoy
ya ponerse a dos del récord de Rochas
Maris dentro de los Yankees que para
muchos es el récord que está
completamente limpio en el béisbol y
haber elevado su promedio a 316 es decir
ponerse solo a un punto del líder de
averaje que es Luis arraes coloca a
Aaron George ante las puertas de la
triple Corona es el líder en carreras
impulsadas es el líder en cuadrangulares
y de quedar líder en average ganaría la
triple Corona 10 años después de haberlo
logrado el venezolano Miguel Cabrera y
yo creo que sería eso un sello para que
la discusión se incline a su favor a la
hora del voto por el jugador más valioso
si no gana la triple Corona tú me
preguntarías
firme candidato todavía Sí yo creo que
George yotani el pitcher y chojeiro el
bateador combinados tiene argumentos
para pelear por el jugador más valioso
pero si Aaron George logra la triple
Corona estará sellando pienso yo su
boleto para hacer ese ganador Mary y
precisamente para hablar de esta recta
final de la temporada regular vamos a
conversar qué nos podemos esperar vamos
a ir a una una definición de
clasificados bajo un nuevo formato
porque ahora son 12 y no 10 los equipos
que pasan a las series de división qué
podemos esperarnos de estos últimos días
Mira va a ser muy interesante en la Liga
Nacional lo que lo que puede suceder en
el liderato del este de la división este
porque los lideran en este momento pero
Atlanta está solamente a un juego y
ellos todavía se van a ver y allí pueden
cambiar las cosas lo que no pareciera
que va a cambiar es quiénes van a estar
presentes en la postemporada en la liga
americana y en la liga nacional en la
Liga Nacional tenemos que ya
clasificaron los astros de Houston Los
Yankees de Nueva York parece que van a
ser los líderes del este y los indios de
clevelan en el centro el comodín es lo
que está peleado Ahí está Toronto y
Tampa prácticamente seguro junto con los
Marineros de Seattle porque ya los los
oreones de Baltimore muy a mi pesar
parecen lejos a cuatro juegos de del
liderato
o del comodín van a clasificar tres por
liga en la Liga Nacional los Dodgers ya
están Dueños del Oeste ya están
clasificados así como los astros de
Houston en la liga americana están como
te decían los mets con los astros muy
cerquita los Cardenales de San Luis y
luego el comodín están Los Bravos de
Atlanta que es lo único que está reñido
los padres de San Diego y los fieles de
Filadelfia bilboki todavía con un chance
claro Aunque la tienen difícil porque
tienen que ganarle a Filadelfia y a San
Diego pero están solamente a dos juegos
Esas son las peleas realmente
que merecen atención porque ya todo lo
demás parece estar definido brevemente